any change in the regime needs careful
consideration by the prison management
so I've gone away on business for a few
days my assistant G is working with a
team on potential new products for the
lunch delivery menu
the morning's work done obsessive
cleaner renee has finished clearing up
his workstation but he won't muck in to
help others
teen working that night I don't really
work like that use something wash it up
simple in it really introduced easier
ranae's I'm alright Jack attitude is
making G job impossible this is a
kitchen it's a team there's stuff to be
doing everyone needs to chip in and then
move done really well with it apart from
any who will sit on his work surface
like that until we go
and I've tried I've approached him and
said you know can you help out no miss
like I've done my stuff and and then it
just kicked off with your job
everybody back in that room now I'm
quite a ballsy female so having a man
yell at me I'm a supposed to be
different if I was standing there on my
own but the funny thing is the other
guys come jump to our defense but yeah
the hot race is a little bit just a tad
this is our [ __ ] job greater good we
flap our traders over to endure and
women are you got twin girls
oh yeah yeah however when you had them
[ __ ] have to demonstrate the
professionalism of my team
the Wellington has to be cooked to
perfection oh that's good